In the early days of the 1980s,
an unknown stalker was doing the rounds in the U S praying,
mainly on young homosexual men, one after the other,
they fell victim to illnesses considered to be quite rare until that time
patterns bands were merged leading to the discovery of a new infection leading
to the syndrome that would be dubbed the plague of the 21st century,
but plague that would carry with it.
The stigma of behaviors considered by some to be morally reprehensible
HIV. In today's episode,
we will trace the origins of the disease from the first publicized cases in the
U S to the later research pointing to the first outbreaks across the Atlantic.
Along the way we will discover the truth behind the man still known as patient
zero.
Right.
In AIDS were not easily identified at the start.
It took time for medical researchers to piece together.
The clues that would lead to the identification of a new illness.
The first recorded events in that trail of clues was a morbidity and mortality
reports published by the centers for disease control and prevention.
On June the fifth, 1981.
This report described five cases of a rare type of pneumonia, pneumocystis,
Caryn, I or PCP.
This is a type of infection of the lungs caused by the fungus pneumocystis
jiroveci, which leads to difficulty in breathing a high fever and dry cough.
The patients were young, previously healthy gay men in Los Angeles.
All of them showed signs of severe immune deficiencies. Within days,
doctors across the U S submitted reports of similar cases to the CDC,
less than a month later on the 3rd of July,
the New York times published an article about the outbreak of a rare cancer,
41 gay men in New York and California had been affected by Kaposi's sarcoma and
abnormal growth of small blood vessels. That manifest itself with,
from pink or purple spots on the skin.
It can become life-threatening when it affects the internal organs,
more and more homosexual men fellow with rare conditions. Very often,
they were associated with immune deficiencies in January of 1992,
some of the patients and their friends and families founded gay men's health
crisis.
This organization would become the first nonprofit community-based HIV
service provider,
but at the time they didn't know what they were fighting against. Very soon,
it became clear that whatever was infecting us citizens was not only targeting
homosexuals on July. The 16th of 1982,
a CDC reports featured three cases of PCP and heterosexual.
Hemophiliac men hemophilia is a genetic condition,
which prevents blood from clotting in the 1980s.
Patients suffering from it required frequent blood and plasma transfusions
around the same time.
The first cases of a new disease were being recorded in Sub-Saharan Africa and
Uganda. This disease was nicknamed slim, Jim,
as it caused a massive weight loss among its victims.
Later that year at the time AIDS was first used to identify the new disease.
It was the 24th of September when the CDC released the first definition of AIDS,
a disease,
at least moderately predictive of a defect in cell mediated immunity occurring
in a person with no known cause for diminished resistance to that disease.
Gay men were in a group among which the disease was most prevalent,
but it quickly became the parents that they were by.
No means the only victims in January of 1983,
the CDC recorded the first two female patients.
They were partners of men living with AIDS,
which suggested a sexual transmission of the disease. Firstly,
in may of 1983,
two teams of researchers found the cause behind this new illness.
First was the team headed by Dr.
Francois Barson NuSI and Dr. Luc Montagnier at the pastor Institute in
France, they isolated a virus,
which they believed was responsible for causing AIDS,
which they call the lab or lymphadenopathy associated virus. Later that year,
Dr. Robert Gallo of the national cancer Institute in the U S cultivated lab
specimens in his lab, identifying it as a retrovirus.
This is a type of virus which can insert a DNA copy of its genome into a host
cell in order to replicate in June of 1984,
Dr. Gallo and Dr. Mantini held a joint press conference announcing the
discovery that a retrovirus was responsible for causing AIDS.
The French doctor called it lab Gallo called it HDL V3.
They later changed the names of human immunodeficiency virus, HIV.
[Inaudible].
Cronin age stands for acquired immunodeficiency syndrome and is the advanced
stage of the infection caused by HIV.
HIV is a rather aggressive virus which targets the cells of the immune system,
making a person more vulnerable to other infections and diseases,
which are called opportunistic infections.
Healthy individual can contract HIV by contact with certain bodily fluids,
from an infected patients with detectable viral load.
Most commonly this happens during unprotected sex.
So through the sharing of injection drug equipments,
a person who is HIV positive is considered to have progressed to AIDS when the
number of their white blood cells of the CD four type falls below 200 cells per
cubic millimeter,
or regardless of their CD four counts when they have developed one or more
opportunistic infections, opportunistic diseases,
most commonly associated with AIDS,
which can often lead to the death of a patients include bacteria and infections
like salmonella, tuberculosis, and pneumonia,
less well-known consequences are fungal infestations like thrush and PCP.
However,
the weakening of immune deficiencies brought about by HIV can also lead to the
onset of certain types of cancer. For instance, lymphoma and Kaposi sarcoma.
As of today, there is no cure for HIV. However,
certain treatment regimens known as hot or highly active antiretroviral
therapy can help patients live with HIV without it degenerating into AIDS.
And we'll get into those a little bit later without this therapy.
People with AIDS typically survive about three years. Sadly,
if they contract a dangerous opportunistic illness that life expectancy falls to
one year,
patients who are HIV positive can live for 10 to 15 years without any noticeable
symptoms. And even if they manifest, they can be easily mistaken,
but those of a less serious illness like flu when HIV degenerates into AIDS,
common symptoms include rapid weight, loss, diarrhea, fatigue, memory loss,
and depression. Again,
these symptoms are not exclusive to AIDS and can be related to other illnesses.
That is why the only certain way to diagnose HIV and AIDS is to get the
appropriate test, to avoid an uncontrolled spread of the infection.
The most common way is through which AIDS is transmitted,
it's unprotected sex and the sharing of needles by drug users.
But there are other less common avenues. For example,
a mother can pass HIV to a child during pregnancy birth or breastfeeding.
There have been cases of health workers being infected when handling HIV
contaminated needles or other sharp objects,
particularly if they are not utilizing the recommended personal protective
equipment.
A patient may also receive a transfusion of blood or plasma from a donor who was
HIV positive.
Nowadays this risk is extremely low because of the scrutiny that blood donations
received,
but there had been many cases recorded in the early 1980s before rigorous
testing was put in place. Finally,
there is an extremely low risk of contracting HIV via oral contact.
For example, if an individual is bitten by an infected patient,
or if two partners base with bleeding gums or mouth ulcers share a deep kiss
HIV, absolutely can't be spread by insect bites, physical contact, uh,
water, saliva, tears, or sweats.
HIV could affect anyone regardless of sexual orientation, race, ethnicity,
gender, or age. However,
certain groups are at a higher risk of contracting HIV.
The records of the centers for disease control and prevention show that in the U
S certain demographics are more likely to get this virus.
According to 2018 CDC statistics, gay, bisexual,
and other men who have sex with men accounted for 69% of all new HIV
diagnoses. The next largest category,
it was heterosexual is accounting for 24% of new cases followed by injection
drug users.
At 7% records show that the incidents of new cases disproportionately
affects ethnic minorities. For example,
African-Americans are about 13% of the overall population in the U S and yet
they accounts for 42% of the newly infected Hispanic saw 18% of the population,
but account for 27% of the HIV positive people who identify as white are
70% of us citizens,
but they are just a quarter of the overall instant patients.
All things considered gay African-American men,
all the category at highest risk of contracting HIV representing
25% of all cases.
[Inaudible].
So let's go back to the 1980s.
It was becoming clear to medical professionals and even part of the general
public that this new disease favored.
Certain groups defined as the four H's homosexuals, heroin addicts,
haemophiliacs, and Haitian immigrants.
The first advocacy group started to take shape in 1983 on may the second people
with AIDS stage their first public demonstration in San Francisco.
In the following months, patient groups issued the Denver principles,
a charter stating their right to be involved in policy decisions and to be
called people with AIDS, not AIDS victims. On the 22nd of November,
the world health organization held its first meeting to assess the global impact
of AIDS. By this date,
at least one case of the disease had been reported in each region of the world.
It took another couple of years though,
before AIDS fully entered the public consciousness. First,
it was thanks to an Indiana teenager on June, the 30th, Ryan White,
a boy living with hemophilia was denied admission to a local school.
He had been infected with HIV from a blood transfusion.
Ryan went on to speak publicly against the stigma and discrimination that many
AIDS patients experienced. The other event was the death of rock Hudson.
On the 2nd of October,
the legendary Hollywood actor died of AIDS leaving $250,000 to help set up the
American foundation for AIDS research or amfAR fellow actress.
Elizabeth Taylor acted as national chairperson for amfAR,
which gave a further boost to the disease awareness efforts.
The first few years of the epidemic and their impact,
especially on the gay community were recorded in the 1987 book.
And the band played on by Randy Shilts,
a journalist at the San Francisco Chronicle.
The book introduced a real life character,
the gay Canadian flight attendant to its succumb to AIDS on March the 30th,
1984. Thanks to his good looks. Charisma field of work,
the flight attendant traveled across the country having a string of sexual
encounters along the way. Apparently in a typical year,
you could have up to 251 night stands while researching his book.
Schultz came across the cluster study,
published in the American journal of medicine with this study CDC investigators,
or to drop a map of sexual encounters among several people with AIDS.
The study featured a diagram illustrating this network of relationships at the
center of the largest cluster responsible for directly infecting eight patients.
This paper had identified one person as patient zero. According to Schiltz,
this patient was ultimately responsible for introducing HIV and AIDS to the
United States. For years after Schultz's work had been published.
A medical addiction rate still refers to patient zero as an individual
identified as the person who introduced HIV in the United States.
According to CDC records, patient zero and airlines do it. In fact,
nearly 50 other persons before he died,
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome in 1984,
that airline Stewart was the Canadian flight attendant we discussed earlier,
and his name was Gayton Douga.
It was born in Quebec city, Canada on February the 20th, 1953.
He worked for a period as a hairdresser in Toronto,
before moving to Vancouver there,
he realized his dream of becoming a flight attendants,
working for our Canada while on duty. He frequently traveled across Europe,
the Caribbean and the us with his favorite destination being San Francisco would
love to attend the annual pride parades.
He flew to San Francisco as often as he could enjoying many of the sexual
encounters. That Gaten was 26. When he first displayed symptoms of ill health.
In this case, swollen lymph nodes. A year later in 1980,
Brown spots appeared under his skin Gaten at the object to the biopsy,
which revealed that he had Kaposi's sarcoma.
Gaten had to undergo several cycles of chemotherapy with all the side effects
that go along with that from inconvenience to agonizing pain,
despite losing much weight and all of his hair gazing continued to sports,
cutting edge, look wearing fashionable headbands and designer clothing.
By this point,
the clinical community had linked Kaposi's do the new disease targeting
homosexuals. It was referred to as gay cancer and a letter to Ray Redford,
a format lover and friends do go out, described his mental stages.
He tried to learn more about the disease and to keep it symptoms at Bay,
he wrote my mind is finding peace again. You are right.
I must upgrade my attitude towards a full recovery, but you know,
there is always the storm that strike you when less expected.
The CDC started interviewing gay men with Kaposi sarcoma and soon realized that
at least four of them had slept with Gaten,
took parts in this cost to study two cooperating, eagerly and volunteering.
Plenty of detailed information on the names and addresses of his previous
partners.
The CDC made it clear to gate that the new deadly illness may have been spread
sexually. According to Schiltz in November of 1982,
Gaden Duka was even confronted by a San Francisco public health official about
his sexual habits was asked to avoid having sex prevent further spreading of the
disease, but he flatly refused. It was his right.
He said to do what he wanted with his body. By that time,
do you go ahead and move to San Francisco permanently anti frequency,
the local bath houses looking for new partners,
his success streak was such to Rouse the jealousy of other gay men in the area.
Some even conspired to have him evicted from the town.
It was because of behaviors such as this,
that Schiltz harshly branded duga as the equivocal version of typhoid,
Mary eventually left San Francisco and resettled in Vancouver.
His body was now consumed with opportunistic infections,
the most serious one being PCP, the fungal pneumonia,
the infection progressed inexorably Gaten moved back to his native Quebec city
where he passed away on March the 30th, 1984, age 31.
The cluster study was published some weeks after his death,
all the remains of Gaytan for life. It was a circle at the center of a diagram.
It was connected, do eight other circles, LA three, six, eight, and nine.
And NYU three, four, nine, and 15 Gayton circle was marked by zero.
The only thing is it was not a zero.
It was the letter O the cluster study marked its participant by location.
Gayton Dougal had been recorded as out of California,
or simply over short Randy Shilts.
His work had been critics with Cambridge historian, Richard McKay among them.
McCay points out that Shilts misunderstood the letter over a number zero.
The diagram of the cluster study was not supposed to illustrate what may have
been the epicenter of the pandemic in the U S it was intended to find a link
between two outbreaks of Kaposi sarcoma and other opportunistic illnesses.
One on the West coast and the other on that East Gasten, Oh,
went to certain SF one where the links between East and West,
the Gaten just happened to be placed at the center.
Some of the other interviewees in the study were as promiscuous,
if not more so than Douga, but they could not,
or would not provide as many details as the Canadian stearate.
Hence his circle marks with an O appeared as more interconnected to other men.
That's why it was easier to represent them graphically at the center of the
diagram.
Schultz is that as a Michael Denny admitted that the two had overplayed the
responsibilities of dougga in the epidemic in order to make,
and the band played on more appealing.
They painted Gaten as the villain of the piece, patient zero,
the typhoid Gary,
if you like introduced HIV and AIDS to the U S the intention was ultimately
noble increased circulation of the book to raise awareness about HIV,
as well as the stigma and indifferent suffered by gay people with AIDS at the
hands of authorities and the public, but in doing so,
the book created the full Smith of patient zero scapegoats in gate and do gap.
Even if the Canadian man was not an actual patient,
zero shelter's book makes it clear that he stubbornly continued to spread HIV
through unprotected sex, but that claim is disputed as well.
The CDC first data that AIDS was sexually transmitted in January of 1983
Gayden's discussions with the CDC and the San Francisco health official took
place in 1982, Dugas behavior was certainly promiscuous.
He definitely lacked caution, but it wasn't as brazenly,
irresponsible as portrayed in the book.
He was not consciously infecting as many menisci Curt.
What really matters to us is that HIV in the U S did not start with Gaten.
It most likely cannot be traced to one single individual,
and most likely did not start in the late 1970s or early 1980s.
Considering the HIV you can take as long as 15 years to display symptoms,
many people could have been infected long before then in October of 1987,
an article in the Chicago Tribune reported a story about tests, wrong samples,
belonging to a teenage male, for instance, Louis,
the samples tested positive for HIV. And in fact,
the individual had died from an AIDS like condition in 1969 and nature
article in 1990,
it found that tissue samples from a British sailor had also tested positive for
HIV.
It died in Manchester from PCP in 1959 Moakley it was pointed
to an earlier origin of the disease and to a location,
many miles away from North America in 1983,
a joint Belgian and American research trip to Ziad.
Now the democratic Republic of Congo established that a similar disease to AIDS.
It was widespread that affecting mainly heterosexual men and women in 1987
medical journal,
the Lancet found evidence of HIV like infections in central Africa,
dating back to 1959.
Researchers were closing in on the place of origin of this plague of the 21st
century. And it was Sub-Saharan Africa.
Uh.
The credited ferries on the origins of AIDS is the one dubbed cops.
Hunter theory.
One of the proponents is microbiologist Jack pay Paul in his 2011,
works the origin of AIDS see proposes a likely travel route from central Africa
to North America and the rest of the world.
HIV likely originated as a pathogen in primate populations.
Most probably chimpanzees late stage infected chimps developed a syndrome called
Sid Simian immunodeficiency sometime in the early 1920s,
the virus jumped species.
This is when the virus somehow relocated from an infected ape into the
bloodstream of a human.
The most likely candidates would be a Hunter whose open wounds were infected by
the chimpanzees blood, the cut Hunter. In other words, in the 1920s and 1930s,
French equatorial Africa,
and the Belgian Congo enjoyed close trade and employment ties,
meaning that any infected individual could have traveled across highly populated
centers by short boat rides, spreading the disease further and further PayPal.
In fact,
found evidence of a disease similar to AIDS causing an outbreak in a railway
camp in French equatorial Africa in the 1920s and 19, 1930s,
HIV may have spread via sexual contact, but also via estrogenic transmission.
These are infections caused by doctors, reissuing unsterilized needles,
travelers, and sailors.
Visiting central Africa may have contracted HIV as early as the 1950s. However,
PayPal was able to establish with more certainty,
a link between Zaja and the Caribbean. During the 1960s,
several thousand Haitian were recruited to work in Zaja.
It is possible that many of them became HIV positive and carried the infection
back to their country from hazy HIV made its way to North America via two
avenues, the trans national blood industry and sex tourism,
a study published in nature in October, 2016,
ascertains that blood and plasma collected from Haiti by New York hospital was
indeed HIV positive by Cambridge,
a story and Richard McKay argues that Haiti was a popular destination for
American gay men. Looking for sexual liaisons from these two entry points,
the virus gradually spread to haemophiliacs, heroin uses,
and time of sexuals ends. Of course,
there are scores of potential Haitian immigrants jumping the Gulf to the United
States.
The four H's that we already mentioned through the effects of paper Mackay and
other researchers.
It is clear now that the whole concept of Douga as patient zero is
more or less debunked.
The first outbreak of what could be called AIDS dates back at least half a
century before.
And it went completely undetected before it swelled into what appeared to be an
unstoppable pandemic.
Since the beginning.
You have the epidemic.
76 million people have been infected with the HIV virus and about
33 million people have died of AIDS related infections.
Luckily advances in medical science have made it possible for HIV positive
patients to live much longer than ever before.
What used to be a fatal disease has now become a chronic illness.
It can't be cured,
but it can be managed through the regular use of antiretroviral drugs.
The first treatment indicated for HIV was approved by the FDA in 1987 in July of
1996, the 11th international AIDS conference established hot is a breakthrough
approach leading to a drop in morbidity and mortality advances in other disease
areas have also made it possible to prevent or treat the symptoms of the most
common opportunistic illnesses. However,
HIV and AIDS are far from being completely defeated at the end of 2019,
about 38 million people were estimated to be living with HIV across the globe.
During that scene, yet 690,000 people died of AIDS.
300,000 of them died in Eastern and Southern Africa alone.
Despite some advancements in treatment rates,
Sub-Saharan Africa is still the region suffering the most from HIV and amongst
the infected about three fifths or women and young girls, according to UN AIDS,
the joint United nations program on HIV AIDS.
The progress of the HIV crisis is related to the low supply of
antiretroviral therapies. Naturally,
this is a situation which may be exacerbated by the concurrent pandemic.
We are now going through with COVID-19,
but UN AIDS identifies another set of reasons. Gender inequalities,
lack of access to secondary education for girls scarcity of sexual and
reproductive health services. There's also the ongoing stigma,
which prevents HIV, positive people,
and at-risk populations from seeking treatments and preventative advice.
Now we've mainly focused on the American HIV story,
but here today's conclusion, I'd like to bring things closer to home. In 1987,
millions of households in the UK received an information booklet on the risks of
HIV and AIDS. The booklet was tying to an effective TV ad campaign,
and it used Frank language on the matter of transmission VAR sexual intercourse.
The tagline of this department of health campaign was don't die of ignorance.
It drove the point home during any public crisis knowledge and the responsible
behavior that grows out of this are really key. As you've seen today,
ignorance about the disease caused millions to die,
that ignorance and its brother prejudice can also isolate condemn and
taint the memory of those who don't deserve it.
So I really hope you found today's video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe as always.